Steel Magnolias 30 years old if you
believe it my life just spins around and
all these wonderful artists I get a
chance to work with I see some of them
some of us are aging and some of us are
not but we're still around please call
me
it's the tear jerker even pink can't get
enough of two words steel magnolias it's
30 years old this year I can't handle
that but I love Dolly Parton I've always
loved Dolly Parton she is incredible but
here are some things you might not know
about these steel magnolias for starters
Julia Roberts was just 20 years old when
she landed her breakout role pink is my
signature color it was a huge learning
experience you know I mean I was with
all these women and there was this
enormous wealth of information about
everything you know not just acting the
life or whatever these women were
dropping these pieces information like
wet sponges and I was running around
picking them all up like I want to keep
this one and I would remember this and
you know so it was it was a big a big
time for me by the time filming wrapped
Julia was dating her co-star Dylan
McDermott they were even engaged before
calling it quits in 1990 another secret
from this set dolly and Darryl had to go
to beauty school to play their parts in
the movie because this is going in the
hair new hole of Fame and remember this
scene yeah
dolly was cutting Julia's hair for real
now I'm having to cut everybody's hair
I've become like a beautician in my own
family now it's like a job and I'm not
getting paid before you were a member of
that time well I love working with all
those women for one thing and that was
such a wonderful story to do
[Music]